hey Luke here at the altar boys YouTube
channel and today i am doing a short but
important product review okay i don't
have sponsors on my channel
I was just on amazon.com buying bike
parts and I discovered this candied
bacon jerky if you like beef jerky and
you like bacon you've got to try candied
bacon jerky I have never seen this I
have never eaten it but I mean how can
you not do that and I wanted to share
this important milestone in my life with
you guys I wanted you to be here when I
tried candied bacon jerky for the first
time so let's open this up I have really
hyped this up in my head I don't know if
there's any way reality can meet
expectations here
alright salut yeah well it feels quite
substantial and it looks good man that
is oh man I'm getting excited it's not
super strong smelling but it oh it's
it's it's got like campfire campfire ham
smell well it smells a little bit more
like a ham than than bacon but it's good
this smells really good mmm
it's a little bit crumbly it's it's not
crisp and it's not like ham or anything
you know it's definitely preserved meat
but it's got a subtle but not
overbearing like candied flavor to it it
really does taste a little bit more like
a ham like a really good Virginia ham
you know the brown sugar glaze on it is
not bad at all though this is best by
January 16 2019 or how long this has
been the package that just blew my mind
a little bit
it says ingredients brown sugar yeah
grade a maple syrup yeah thick sliced
bacon see
that's it that's my kind of ingredients
list that's pretty awesome okay so
apparently their website is bacon
mama-jama calm maybe not like Facebook
Twitter and Instagram accounts made in
North Carolina so not too far from here
and I bought this off of amazon.com so
I'll put a link in the description where
you can buy it off of Amazon but that's
really good I think I might have to buy
a couple more of these and keep these in
my my tackle bag for when we need a
little boat snack if I think to is there
is it really any preservatives or in is
this you know there's a load of sugar
and maple syrup in it but not too bad I
gotta give some of this to my wife this
is good we go check this out you pick a
bigot you got you gotta try some of this
here you like that what do you think
buddy you like there so yeah Nathan
liked it Becket liked it even Jacobs
seem to be digging it they have a lot of
different flavors apparently I saw they
were selling like a sriracha flavored so
if you like spicy spicy bacon jerky you
can do that as well but I definitely got
a sweet tooth so any rate um thanks for
watching guys hope you enjoyed this
product review and if I see any more
good things that I really like I'll make
sure to let you guys know I'll put links
in the description to where you can buy
this and I will also put some other
links to more information about this
product thanks for watching guys every
day